I'm really proud of all that
you've done with Project Compass.
>> Thanks.
I had some rough moments but
I definitely learned a lot too.
>> What's your next step?
>> I was thinking that I should
try to learn more about my users,
see how I can reach more people.
>> Sounds like you want
to analyze some data.
That's what data analysts do.
Data analysts make informed
decisions about data.
Let's check it out.
Data analysts solve many
different types of problems.
They identify meaningful relationships,
patterns or trends from datasets.
Data analysts built reports and
data dashboards on mint.com so users
can track and visualize their spending.
They also use applied statistics and
machine learning algorithms.
Facebook's facial recognition software
uses an algorithm to create a template
based on a person's facial
features to suggest
who you should tag in your photos.
They also represent data in engaging
ways with data visualizations.
One of my favorite data visualization
blogs is Information is Beautiful.
They take ideas, issues, and
data to create visualizations for
people to understand complex data.
Netflix, the online movie and
TV streaming service is known
to make data driven decisions.
They analyze data points such as
what time of day movies are watched,
the time spent selecting movies,
and how often playback is stopped,
to predict the perfect
viewing option for users.
Amazon uses big data to drive
their recommendations feature.
They take data points such
as your previous purchases,
the items you add to your cart or
previous ratings to make suggestions
about products you may be interested in.
Data analysts at Hired,
created a State of U.S.
Salary Report to give visibility into
the job market for software engineers.
Let's hear from Jessica,
who worked on this report at Hired.